make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so picking up in our last video or
I guess from our last video with
Superman rebirth this was kind of like
an interim story right and like bindus
will do that from time to time it's not
an intern story and so far is this like
has nothing to do with the main event
it's one of these interim stories is
like it transitions from something to
something else and and bindus really
does that frequently right like in the
middle of a story arc you'll have like
an issue where things happen and you'll
end up being left with like a lot more
questions and you get answers too
because it's kind of building up to
really this sort of revelation and like
the final issue which is probably
what'll happen and number six if not in
like the next story arc but in the last
one we had basically picked up where
like Jonathan it essentially led like
his father led Superman Oh directly to
where where you know jor-el was that the
grandfather of uh I guess the father of
Superman and the grandfather of John and
then in turn like once they arrived
there's this massive conflict between
really like the Santa gariands and like
like all these crazy races right like
this warrior race called the khuns I'm
not really sure how you pronounce that
it's khu NBS I never really knew how to
pronounce their name but it's like this
huge conflict taking place and the funny
thing is that Superman's powers aren't
really working the way they're supposed
to in the sense that like he can't
really use his x-ray vision does hearing
doesn't work that well now one of the
things to hit on here is that that
business doesn't really say the Superman
is powerless right and that's how some
people will interpret it like well
vintners the same Superman has no powers
no not at all first of all when it comes
to like to super hearing there is no
sound in space except for like what's
going on inside ships so outside of that
like you really don't know a whole lot
about what people are saying I mean you
can kind of hear to a degree it's kind
of finicky
it's happen off and on over the course
of Superman's mythos but his x-ray
vision is having a hard time because
there's literally everything everywhere
so it's like difficult to tell what all
is going on at least from where he's at
in the moment now of course like moving
closer he probably able to pick up on
people or be able to see inside of a
ship if he was like standing right
outside of it but in the middle of all
that he's basically like met by the
arrival of jor-el and of course he and
he and Jonathan also start jumping into
the fray as well now here's the funny
thing about this and this is what Ben is
really kind of hits on the nose is is on
this surface you would expressly remand
it kind of like jump into the fray and
start battling but the funny thing about
this is that Superman it's like I don't
really know what's going on and so
because I don't know what's going on
what I need are answers what I need is
to know what's happening here in order
to figure out like how all this started
and like who's at fault if anybody's at
fault at all so what it is is it turns
into a situation of like disarming
people now the reason why one of the big
reasons why Superman does this is
because Jonathan's here and he basically
says like Jonathan needs to
see how a superhero's supposed to
function now the opposite opposite side
of that coin is if Jonathan was not here
I would just fight everybody that kind
of seems to be what's going on but again
it's sort of like Superman would do this
anyway right I mean that's what we would
expect from from this kind of a
character is he would start asking
questions and trying to figure things
out now behind the scenes Batman will
probably fight and then like figure it
out at the same time which is kind of
interesting but Superman starts
traveling from one group to the next
sort of speaking to them in a way that
like meshes with them right like he's
kind of adapting to how it is that they
function as a people so the thanagarians
are very proud race and so it's hey look
like I realized that you guys are you
guys you guys do your own thing I don't
have authority over you what I need you
guys to do is stand down and ultimately
they do right because if Superman showed
up on the doorstep of the thanagarian
race and said stop shooting they would
ignore him and they'd probably start
shooting at him right because it's like
they're a very very ancient and very
haughty race and it's you don't tell us
what to do we were around when you were
you know before you even thought it when
it comes to the the kun race because
they're basically like a warrior race
it's stand down or I'm gonna destroy you
all and then once he actually gets to
the trillium it's well this is a race
that respects Superman so I'm going to
speak them and you know speak to them in
that that fashion they recognize me for
my strength and so on and so forth and
so I will address that accordingly is
one of these things where he kind of
becomes everything to everyone as he as
he sort of makes his way through and
once they're all done once they're all
standing down then he talks directly
with with jor-el and again that's when
things kind of get murky jor-el is a
very murky character here he's very
cloak-and-dagger and he really has been
throughout Bendis is run and even before
Bendis when he was mr. Oz it was dr.
Manhattan yanked him from Krypton's
final destruction and then brought him
to what's basically the present day more
or less or at least he's been here you
know for a huge amount of time and and
like he was he was very mysterious we
didn't really know what his motivations
were and even now we don't fully know
all we know is it like he took Jonathan
with him into space so Jonathan can
understand what it meant to be a hero
and how small he is on the grand scheme
of things and the impact he can have if
he allow if he acts as a hero and allows
his legacy to flourish but but in this
discussion between Superman and his
father and though of course one they're
speaking at SuperSpeed and two like
there's a lot of I don't really trust
you that's going on here you have
jewelry FC banners kinda like okay so
basically what you're telling me here is
this is all just circumstantial right
like you're just going through space one
day and then like all these races
started attacking you all of a sudden
and like robos are is back the guy who
originally basically led to the
destruction of Krypton who you know
Bendis kind of changed that up a bit but
uh you have him here you have like
General Zod both of whom escaped
zone you've got like these guys here so
basically you were minding your own
business and you're just caught in the
middle of a conflict like this it's I
don't believe that for a second but they
don't really get any answers here they
don't really get any straight
explorations and even when Superman asks
questions he doesn't get straight
answers his father kind of blows him off
as as they looked once I fix my ship
then we'll be able to teleport out of
here as it was it's almost one of these
things were it's like his father's kind
of buying time and basically saying like
I'm trying to fix the ship and
everything and trying to think of an
answer to give his give give Superman
and to give Jonathan Kent once they
leave so that they can you know
essentially be be satisfied in a lot of
ways jor-el plays on this familiar
familiar ties with them like well I'm
their family they'll believe me you know
it's it's intriguing to kind of see that
happen of course you also have Robles
all who basically comes back a little or
rather who basically comes back and then
like starts attacking Superman and of
course you've got General Zod who shows
up and does the same thing now again the
motivation behind these characters is
that locals are believed he was doing
the right thing by saying hey look like
Krypton's gonna be destroyed and so on
and so forth and then you have General
Zod who's just an enemy of Superman
right but like where Ruggles are thought
he was doing the right thing and then
eventually came to blows with Superman
they've both become his enemies and then
when Superman locked him away in the
Phantom Zone their motivation is to come
back and like destroy Superman so it's
it's relatively thin but it works for
the for the story as it's being told but
it's kind of a funny thing because
Jonathan fighting fighting Zod is no
small thing and even Jonathan kind of
overestimates his powers to degree like
he just kind of flies out there
haphazardly
and just starts like fighting General
Zod and that's not what you do you're
talking about a guy who has who has
powers on par with Superman in some
cases can even be more powerful than
Superman that basically has like all
this tactical military training behind
it because remember when it comes to
Superman as a hero in comparison to
General Zod Superman's flying by the
seat of his pants he doesn't know what
he's doing he's just kind of out there
doing his thing and finding a good fight
and hoping that he wins but Zod has like
all these tactical maneuvers and all
these motivations and schemes what
always defeats General Zod is as
arrogance that's what always cost him
the victory if he cast his arrogance
aside and fought Superman without any
kind of emotional connection or
emotional attachment and focused only on
how can I legitimately beat this guy
then he would crush Superman and it
probably wouldn't even be by a little
bit like it would be if you by a lot and
so with Jonathan like he's really kind
of in over his head and Superman's
dealing with rogles all at the same time
this is happening with with with
Jonathan and so for the most part you
look at this and it's kind of like okay
so these guys are basically like almost
out Matt
they're in a pinch because on one side
he's got Johnny I'm sorry you've got a
jor-el trying to fix the ship otherwise
he would jump in you've got Roble
attacking Superman fighting him which
again he easily hold his own against
Superman
and then you've got Dodd fighting
Jonathan and Zod wouldn't hesitate to
kill Jonathan that's kind of the big
thing about it is like like Zod Stan's
is I don't care who you are if you're
part of the House of El I will kill you
like oh well I will eliminate you so
seeing him do something like that scares
the Wits out of Superman because the
response is like Vogel will kill me if
he gets the chance and like Zod will
kill Jonathan he's fighting a battle on
two fronts and so is it's it's
pandemonium and its really like parental
instincts kicking in but the cool thing
about this is they sort of get a saving
grace out of nowhere when Supergirl
arrives now this kind of leads into the
next story but I do want to talk about
this for a second the arrival of
Supergirl is intriguing here because in
reality while Supergirl is by and large
stronger than Superman you don't really
see that play out all that often a lot
of us because she kind of has her own
stories out there in the middle of
nowhere
that's really what's been going on with
rebirth she's just kind of out there
kind of a satellite character that
doesn't really get involved in the
Justice League and Justice League antics
and she's not really involved a much of
anything that happens she's just sort of
out there doing your own thing but super
a Supergirl has historically been more
powerful than Superman like it's really
been that way since crisis on Infinite
Earths
and even before the events of crisis on
Infinite Earths now a lot of that's
because she's older had more exposure to
like yellow Suns and so on the gist of
this is that because she's older because
she's more capable you would expect her
being thrown in here to turn the tide
and we don't really know if it will but
I assume that it will but that's the
nature of Bendis is we don't really know
well we're kind of wondering it could be
that business is kinda like now there's
no reason Supergirl should be more
powerful than Superman and she'll just
kind of be relegated to like a support
character or it could be that Bendis
goes with like the classic Supergirl
archetype she shows up and absolutely
wrecks ruggles are and General Zod like
takes them out for the most part by
herself I doubt she'll be able to do
that much on her own but there's no
reason to believe that she can because
she's had some pretty impressive feats
in the past so I don't know it's it
really is kind of a crapshoot and it
really is one of these things were like
it can kind of go either way but we had
me said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
come it's explained make sure you guys
have the sub button to become part of
the rob4 if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]